[Applaudissements]
l'algérien type sommet il est comme ça
le dos me do migri mine holloway
alors tu vas voir tu vas voir la semaine
prochaine via le prime spéciale vegas
aller mais à toutes les images prises
bloody mais je me suis claqué dans les
mêmes systèmes et et du rythme on va
travailler gbagbo tu vas tu fais ce que
tu veux mon vieux ou faut saluer deux
jours qu'il est dur avec moi vous
trouvez pas la première fois je suis dur
avec toi on arrive à bout de valence qui
se cassent quitte à ce que ça me retombe
dans la gueule j'ai regardé les anges
c'est sûr questionné sur nrj 12
aujourd'hui la prod les envoie dans un
endroit surprise bien et surprise un don
qu'ils essaient de savoir où c'est les
anges pour mais pour garder la surprise
lors la prod leur a dit vous verrez bien
bien sûr une phrase typique mais raphaël
n'a pas compris que c'est une expression
vous verrez bien